okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone I know that we
have unfortunately a little competition
during today's time frame with some of
the activities for research week but
appreciate those of you who are here
today and we have a speaker from the
outside invited by Joan who actually
served on his dissertation committee
number years ago Morgan price is
currently a family physician and
clinical informatics researcher at the
University of British Columbia right
yeah yes okay and he got his MD degree
from the University of Calgary and a PhD
in health informatics from our friends
up at the University of Victoria and
he's been involved in a number of
projects since then and has some other
collaborations down here as well so I
let him describe what he's going to talk
about and then he wants the session to
be interactive I'm told so I said that's
never a problem with us thank you so we
have about an hour and I do want to make
this session interactive we talked about
what would I want to bring from up north
down here in terms of projects that were
working on and we picked something
that's happening in Alberta we're
involved in the evaluation of a
provincial level deployment of personal
health record a personal health portal
and so that's what I thought we would
talk about today I do want to be
interactive I want us to sort of go off
off script if we want to and talk about
things that are interesting for you that
might relate to this project with some
of the stuff that we're doing up north
first off sort of Who am I I am a family
doctor I work in the inner city so I
work about a day and a half a week doing
clinical medicine with the homeless the
hard to house be with HIV Hep C
addictions and mental health issues in
the inner city of Victoria which I say
in quotes because people go there's no
inner city in Victoria it's this nice
little quaint town
actually about 4,000 people who were
active in our practice currently there
are eight of us working as family
doctors and we have nurses and
psychiatrists and nurse practitioners
all working in a team and I go up to
some of the shelters and stuff as well
so for a population much of a fair
number of of homeless when I'm not doing
that the rest of the week I am an
assistant professor at UBC and this is
where it does get confusing because i
live in victoria and NBC we have one
medical school with four campuses so one
of those campuses happens to be in
victoria so i have cross appointments in
three different departments that you Vic
as well as my home base in the
department of family practice in at ubc
in Vancouver my office is actually in
computer science and I've got grad
students as i was telling joan in three
different departments across two
different universities and we try to fit
them in wherever strategically is best
for their learning my my big research
partner is a Yin's Webber who was a
director software engineering up at uvic
so we do a lot of sort of from
conception through to to deployment
evaluation of clinical information
systems with a big slant on primary care
that's my background and consumer health
and that's we're going to talk about
saying any questions about Who am I and
how on earth I got down
it's all John's fault really I managed
to get her on my committee when I was
doing my PhD in touch come down twice
now yeah it was 450 pages mostly because
of the hundred and fifty figures I think
in pictures and so it comes out and it
did come out of the dissertation so I
wanted to share some of my experience
about evaluating the system I'm going to
tell you about the system I'm standing
in the way I'll move out of the way a
bit here and I'll sort of talk about how
we got involved and history behind it
what we're doing and what we're trying
to do and I think it's it's it's unique
in Canada to have had an independent
group come into a provincial level
project like this and I think it there's
lots of interesting lessons to learn so
hopefully it's going to be a value for
you so what is this Alberta PHP first
off people know where Alberta is I
didn't I didn't draw on that but so it's
one of the provinces it's the second
most western province it's just on the
other side of the Rockies and they a few
years ago had rolled down to a single
health region for the entire province so
everything was being centralized and the
minister of health I can't remember if
it was during an election or shortly
afterwards said we are going to have a
personal health portal for every
elberton in the province and a line item
was written in the budget and tens of
millions of dollars were put into this
project and we were blissfully unaware
and bc that this was going on and at
uvic i was just i think i just finished
up my PhD and was just working on a
postdoc and somebody from a steering
committee and alberta said i don't know
about this evaluation plan it's the big
project I think we should have somebody
evaluate our evaluation plan and i
happen to know some folks over in
Victoria who have had an informatics
program for 30 years and they should
probably come over to an end
and in review so Frances law was invited
to do that and I was his postdoc so I
was then invited to do the evaluation
and off we went to check out what's
happening in Alberta and lo and behold
the evaluation plan was effectively a
satisfaction survey did you like getting
a personal health portal yes or no maybe
we'll have a seven-point likert scale it
was very very simple I'm being a little
tongue-in-cheek there but it effectively
was a multi-million dollar project that
ended up with a satisfaction survey and
we said why don't think that's
appropriate to know that this is
successful and good use of money just to
say I like the color blue and I love the
font choice you made so so we felt to
give value back we just didn't want to
say no it's not sufficiently wanted to
say you could make it more sufficient by
doing certain things so we started to
put together what we would recommend for
them which ended up coming back to us as
a proposal to do the evaluation so what
we started with was a diagram not unlike
this from the from the program that said
we're going to be releasing this
personal health record in phases and
there's going to be at there should be a
portal of anonymous content so a
knowledge base think of it as a
collection of searchable handouts and
other tools that you can say I was just
discharged from hospital and they told
me to go look up congestive heart
failure and they can go get a handout on
congestive heart failure or the diet for
congestive heart failure the next
release would be some more personalized
content so actually putting in a
personal health record future releases
would be then integrating that personal
health record with provincial assets
like the drug repository so the
dispensing record lab systems be able to
schedule appointments with your family
doctor and those were sort of the grand
visions of how this thing would go
released by release and they had this
evaluation accuracy of so just seeing
how it worked and did people like each
one and then they would go and do the
next release
we proposed a much more embedded release
structure in sort of three phases so for
each of the their main deployments we
would start with what I call the
pre-release evaluation so what is it
that you're trying to do are you sure
it's going to get there what are the
potential benefits let's talk about that
let's let's not just say on a PowerPoint
slide it's going to improve care but
let's talk about who it's going to help
what do they look like how are they
going to use it let's get let's get down
to a vision yes so something I'm
concerned about though isn't it even too
late for that at that stage because
you've already done all your
requirements gathering and specification
right what you would you would hope oh
actually no I you wouldn't hope you
would hope that they would be doing this
iteratively and be reflecting on it and
so the idea was to get into that as an
action research project this project was
already in flight when we came on board
remember the money was committed and
actually this is a good point to say is
that this was this was the ticket we are
going to have this for all Burton's it
will be a success and one of the things
that we came back to as well can't
evaluation help it be a success or are
we going to come back at the end of five
years and say well you know we've been
evaluated for five years and now we've
told you it's not a success that we
decided not to do that we decided to
roll it back and try to give feedback
along the way so it's more likely to be
successful that's kind of where this
picture came up you're right you know in
a sort of a waterfall approach a lot of
good requirements the beginning leads
you to the product as they wanted to do
this phased approach ideally their
response to feed into and make some
adjustments don't you ask her to be
interactive please do but I'm surprised
that in the way to describe it the first
phase is just going to be go look up
something because it seems like the
first phase for a health portal should
be you've been told to you know get
information on congestive heart failure
and to have that provided because you
just in terms of the use of the portal
because that's on that that's not a very
tricky specification it's really a
doctor you know says this is the
materials usually they would be pulled
clinic anyway so so I'm just surprised
that they were so slowly staged because
the first use case to me I'm finding it
really hard to even see what the use is
because if the search isn't good a
patient's just going to get frustrated
probably not use the portal at all so
you have a high chance of poor
interaction early on absolutely there's
been lots of concern on this project of
what's our first face that comes out and
will that impact will people never come
back to this so there's and that's
actually been probably a detriment to
the project because people are so
nervous to put out something that that
isn't working they really went that
route just from the privacy perspective
they hadn't got their their personal
health record ready yet they wanted to
get something out there were lots of
again there's we want this personal
health record its personal health portal
I'm going to use that as a sort of
global term it needs to be live and I
mentioned it needs to be live on
November first and that was actually a
mandate so people came back back and
said k by November first we can't what
we'll do this and suddenly it was this
is what we're going to do so that first
release was really to meet a timeline in
some ways and it was actually and I'll
touch on it briefly you it was it was
relatively small what they did and it
wasn't so surprising it was content that
was purchased that was put up on a
website but the idea being here and I'm
going to focus on the personal health
record not the whole portal we wanted
want to know more concretely what was
this deployment going to be if it's a
small deployment to 12 people do we know
the kinds of people and how is this
going to help them a design evaluation
then reflects from here does the tool
meet what we were expecting it would do
and this might be a lab based evaluation
and I'll talk about a couple of them and
then ultimately moving into a deployment
so once it's been put out there what
does it look like for people are they
using it as expected are the expected
benefits from over here actually being
realized by real people and hopefully
through all this each stage we're
feeding forward into the planning cycles
so it might be within this particular
release plan it but it might also be in
subsequent release plans so
that's what we recommended to them so
release 1 i'm not going to talk too much
about this this is the the anonymous the
web the web site that you didn't have to
log into we actually did a survey of
albertans and there were several
thousand phone calls made to random
digit dialing to just find out our
people aware of where they can access
health information where are they told
to go from their health care provider we
wanted to see if that would change over
time as this was deployed now we opted
not to do any design evaluation because
they had effectively bought a product
they were just going to put a logo on
the top of and restructure it a little
bit but it was wasn't a lot to do there
and then we started to look at some
deployment assessment one of the
assumptions in the pre-release was that
people who access the phone system in
Alberta that I don't know if you guys
have a nurse call line kind of system
down here right so we all have access to
a free nurse line in Victoria our in
Canada in each province they have a
system that's in Alberta it's called
healthlink they actually randomly phone
people from the day before go so we pick
you back into this some questions about
the personal health portal to see are
these people then being referred back to
the website and if so what was their
experience like because that was one of
the assumptions that one of the high
users of this group of this website
looking people do for phoning anyway and
they're they're actively seeking health
care talk face-to-face
we found some information the second
release which is what I'm going to speak
a bit more about is when we get into
this personal health record our
pre-release work I'm going to talk about
indie a bit more detail we used some
techniques that we were developing in
Victoria around modeling the circle of
care for a patient and looking at how
that circle care might change when you
introduce technology from a design
perspective we looked at usability
inspection and usability testing and
then we proposed Adelaide cohort study
weren't able to randomly deploy this to
individuals politically that just wasn't
going to happen the government wasn't
prepared to let us have random access to
people to get or not get what looked
like the best we could do was to find
some similar cohorts of patients in
different clinics and be of one group
the portal and then three to six months
later give the next group of the portal
and then to be able to compare and
contrast those two chords and then we
propose to do some additional work as
released three was being planned they
wanted to embed provincial laboratory
results into the into the PHR so that
when you looked at your information it
wasn't just stuff you have put in but lo
and behold I got my a1c values so we did
some information are some information
gathering in British Columbia where we
already had something similar and then
again a sort of a similar plan i'm going
to focus on release to one of our big
challenges here is we needed to find
what canada health infoway loves to call
sufficiently rigorous approaches to
evaluation and it really fit into the
program plan so this is that november
first example what can I do by November
first it's going to help them be better
on November second and that's that's a
real challenge
I want outcomes sorry you line up comes
for a knowledge base I'm going to show
decreased mortality rates by November
purse okay that's not going to happen
let's be realistic and let's see what we
can actually do so we use this model I
don't know if you can see it all in the
back but effectively this this diagram
actually became really useful with some
of the folks the decision they could
understand this flow of time so from a
moment of go live you'd expect the
availability of whatever the component
or product is to go up first as
availability goes up hopefully system
use ghost oh I know that there's a
health record i'm going to go log in and
then if it's good you might log in a
second time if you've logged in a couple
times it might start to change how you
interact with your own behavior when
there is a there's a paper on this VI
the idea is that without use you're not
going to see that clinical behavior
change and without that clinical
behavior change you're not going to see
changes in outcomes so let's see where
we fit in this pathway depending on
where we are compared to November first
and oftentimes of course it's here right
to talk about availability first and
then the next cycle we can talk about
system views and we can sort of build up
from there so this was actually
surprisingly helpful for for working
with our colleagues in Alberta to try to
structure what we wanted to evaluate
when and why we were excluding certain
things because it wasn't realistic to
start evaluating patient outcomes heart
attack rates to two months after
deploying a personal health record just
you're not going to see that change so
don't look for it because it you'll have
a false failure and those two words were
actually very useful nobody wanted to
false failure they didn't want to
failure at all so
okay so I'm going to pause there for a
moment to talk a little bit about the
approach in a couple of the frameworks
that we started to to consider at the
beginning of this project any questions
or comments ya know I shouldn't say use
methods for for planning and deployment
there's lots of planning and lots of
work going on but they were there wasn't
sort of they didn't take an agile
approach necessarily they had this
release cycle thinking but there wasn't
that and they were looking very much
they looked at the procurement and I had
procured a particular product and then
it was configuration of that product so
they fit into the the vendors unnamed
process
yeah maybe in two slides I'll talk about
a little bit about that because we did
use those and they've got a couple of
diagrams any other questions okay so I
want to talk to where we are so this
this was all happening my son was just
understanding gravity a little bit at
that point was falling down all the time
that's when we went up he's now five and
a half so you know we've been at this
for about five years now so after we
propose all this stuff they came back to
us a few months later and said would you
guys be interested in doing this and we
said yeah okay well we'll come in and
start to do this assessment we did some
of release one and then we got into
release two and that's where I'm going
to spend some time so we this is the
anonymous portal I talked about it
earlier I don't think it's that
interesting unless you guys are really
keen to know about patient handouts of
the doctors all right so the initial
personal health record was a targeted
release and initially envisioned this
has a series of targeted p hrs two
different groups i'm going to go to
cardiac rehab because that's a good
group to work with a they've got a
program they're engaged we can give the
PHR to people as they enter rehab
program eight weeks later they're out of
rehab they will have used it with their
their clinicians their nurses their
physicians and then potentially change
the program over time so that it can use
that in a way to give better follow up
post mi then we can do the same with
copd patients or rheumatoid arthritis
patients or you name it we'll we'll pick
the groups and that was really the plan
from the program's perspective for a
couple of years that they would go out
with these different groups learn
something build some tools for that that
particular group and then build their
way to what they started to call a
general public launch so eventually it
would get out to the whole province but
they could you know at least get some
knowledge through these different cycles
so this is released to so what we have
proposed and I'm going to talk a bit
about the three pieces we weren't able
to do the delayed cohort in the end
interestingly so this was you know can
we do a randomized control trial no we
can't we can't randomly give two okotoks
something that we don't give two red
deer that we can't give to Edmonton and
eventually we boil it down to can we do
a delayed cohort and we've got two
groups that we can work with
unfortunately they weren't able to
recruit the second group so we add one
group so in the end we just did we just
did it affect away a case study so the
pre-release evaluation how many people
are familiar with personas from software
ball okay so we made three personas
these are patient specific there they
are targeting what people talked about
from you know we will we will treat
cardiac rehab patients okay great let's
talk about one of them and then we map
that person down to what the expectation
was and then we validated these personas
and their scenarios with clinicians
patient representatives and groups that
were sort of the stakeholder groups so
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the persona persona isn't a 65 to
85 year old person who you know it is it
is Mark I've mark and 69 he has
congestive heart failure hypertension
osteoarthritis he actually does live in
okotoks and he he's on his computer a
bit he he knows about skype he skypes
with his grandkids who live out atlantic
canada and and this is mark and you get
to know mark and what his goals are and
he's a bit grumpy in that picture but
that's just that picture he's much
happier rest of the time then you start
to sketch out a circle of care for for
mark and this is what John was asking
about it so who is in mark circle of
Karen and who's involved when he has a
heart attack
so he lives in okotoks and over there
he's got a home care nurse the visit
civil once the law he's got his
pharmacist his family doctor and he
knows it was the folks at the lab and so
we sort of built out this story line and
we get to understand these people and
unfortunately he also knows the
paramedics because he has a heart attack
and in okotoks he goes from okotoks to
Calgary because that's what happens and
again we picked these places
intentionally to sort of show this story
and in Calgary has as a whole other
group of providers while he's in the
hospital he's got cardiac nurses and
dieticians and hospital pharmacists and
ot and Pt and a cardiologist and he's
got home care liaison that then helps
structure his plan to come back to
okotoks later on so with this persona we
kind of have a series of scenarios that
we sketched out and his a family doctor
visit before his next heart attack is
another one then he has a heart attack
men's up at hospital he goes to the
cardiac rehab program because remember
that's what they wanted to target the
benefit of this PHR and we sort of wrap
this story around this Sentinel activity
so we'd know that would it help anywhere
leading up to this and would it help
anytime afterwards and try to then drive
out what the what the additional
requirements were and map that back into
what was pre-existing so try to see if
that PHR would actually support mark at
least in theory and then we validated
all these as I said before with the with
clinicians and patients but easier to
reason
so from that pre-release work we set the
expectations it actually gave us the
framework we needed to do the next phase
which was all right now the consortium
of vendors has configured the product
they've gotten our feedback they they're
they're getting closer to go live in a
few months can we can we give them some
specific feedback and this is where we
did usability inspection and usability
testing we had to fit again the needs of
the project to what we were allowed and
not allowed to do so we actually weren't
allowed to do usability testing that
there's the concern which is really
interesting for me it was no we don't
want to have unsafe people coming and
looking at a product it wasn't ready yet
we that's can you do something else okay
if they're pretty safe people I think
they know it's testing but ok so we did
usability inspection force which is for
those of you who aren't familiar it's
sort of an expert walkthrough so
somebody who is an evaluator does the
inspection we use the personas to try to
make it as realistic as possible sort of
did a parallel a heuristic evaluation so
just looking at to the buttons make
sense or this navigation makes sense is
there help on every screen heuristic
style evaluation with the parallel ok
I'm going to be mark I've and I'm going
to wear that hat and I'm going to put in
all my data and our personas actually
have pages of information so we can pull
out I want to put down the fact that I
exercise ok let me put that in and
they'd have actually our analyst has
that that information to be able to put
in and then we would work those those
work through through and see where the
challenges were
yes there was this time they weren't
quite ready for us and then we meant to
usability testing I'm going to merge the
results together so a few months later
we went to usability testing when they
thought they were ready and we actually
did usability testing both letting
people just think aloud explore and then
when they didn't touch certain pieces we
wanted them to we gave them the data
from the personas like Mark I've and so
now I want you to please document the
fact that you have these kinds of
medications and and here's the specific
information so we actually had 21 users
in two different groups which is a good
number for usability test the first
group were sort of picked because they
knew about the project they were
involved from a perspective of
stakeholders the other group were
completely naive but interested
volunteers and so we've got that level
mm-hmm I think it was how did 21 it
because it's it's a combination of two
numbers i think it was we wanted about
10 to 12 of naive users and then there
were a bunch that had volunteered who
were part of the stakeholder group and
we couldn't say no to any of those well
usability is somewhere between 6 and 12
is often the number yeah we just sort of
picked it was and sort of how much time
we had but yeah we wanted to be a little
broader so few more people and we
watched what new stuff was coming out
and interestingly we'll talk about the
findings we didn't learn we learned some
new things with the usability testing
but most of the big box stuff was pretty
obvious during inspection there were a
few things that the users did that we
still can't recreate today and got under
the hood at one point one person got
when we were able to trace it because we
had it all recorded but they actually
got under the hood to a place that
nobody knew they could get to
and and and complete a completely
different user interface to the product
like it was it was just I remember the
student coming back tuna I don't know
where we were I we've been working on
this project for a year and I've never
seen that and eventually they said yes
no there's another back end of the
system and you can't get there from here
oh so I'm going to group these into a
couple of categories so I I think you
may recognize the product I've got a
couple of screenshots but there's
certainly some information architecture
problems I'm a usability guy I'm a
family doctor who likes the screen I
draw things I mean I used to be an
animator I I end up talking about
information architecture and data
quality because I have to just you know
it's the problem behind the system that
makes the system work strangely so
information architecture and this
particular product is quite interesting
so a couple things from the screen side
there was a really deep navigation
hierarchy that was created so here I
don't know if you can read it from the
back but it says health history and
medication so this is already a couple
tabs in view search add and edit health
history and medications here except you
can't this is actually the launch page
to go to those sections to be able to do
those things right nice icons conditions
find more that's where you add a health
condition so you're a couple of layers
down before you can actually add some
data which is really interesting people
were having a hard time finding out
where to put stuff so when you said
please record your blood pressure
because you had a heart attack you want
to make sure your blood pressure is well
controlled we want to check your weight
cuz you might have congestive heart
failure put those two things in please
where would I put that and eventually
people would start to find those things
but they were buried so deeply the other
thing from information architecture that
was really interesting that came out
both inspection and in testing was the
module centric design of this tool so
you couldn't you can create a module
build a widget stick it on any page you
want to
but those were effectively I think
you've sort of in a simple way you can
think of it as sort of a bit of HTML
connected up to a table in the database
it's more more than that but think about
it that way and what was happening was
that the Alberta Health folks were
picking the widgets and not thinking
about how they interacted between the
widgets so here we have ad cholesterol
do we need a cholesterol widget oh this
is this is cardiac rehab this is our
targeted group of course we have to have
a cholesterol widget so when they take
the box of cholesterol widget
unfortunately they also took the box of
lab widget because lab you need to have
because you've got cardiac rehab when
they do lab work but cholesterol widget
with the table lab widget with the table
and never the two will meet so I go in
and I put in my total of my HDL in my
LDL and I apologize this is in Canadian
units interestingly it was in our first
inspection it was all still in US units
in which cholesterol for us is a totally
night you know cholesterol of three is
fantastic very very different down here
so so we actually we had some other just
unit issues that hadn't been thought up
but you then go to another section and
you see your labs and you don't have any
cholesterol there and we see the same
thing with diabetes we see insulin and
we see medications we see an asthma
tracker and we see you know ventolin
being recorded over here and not over
here so this module Center issue doesn't
come up until you walk through the tool
so Morgan what you're saying
pretty close what they had was again it
was it was a feature that was you can
have whichever widgets you want for your
right but the way it was implemented was
very similar to sharepoint and how you
would have sort of you know these what I
contra what share web parts that I think
is what sharepoint calls them but and as
long as you only have one thing that has
a calendar you're fine right because the
calendar widget does its thing but as
soon as you're trying to interrelate
those things it and of course last time
I checked I'm pretty interrelated so I
want to have all those things working
together so there were challenges with
the content there was there was this
concept of we're going to target cardiac
rehab and so what does what does a
cardiac rehab patient need while they
need their cholesterol widget right but
you know they said we do need care
planning yes we need care planning so
that's excellent so you can pick any
care plan you want as long as it's the
cardiac wellness plan because this is a
targeted at cardiac patients but of
course cardiac patients don't have any
mood issues or you know any other
concerns so it became very unfortunately
it was so targeted that was actually a
challenge for us to complete our
scenarios
terminologies were interesting so I
think they pulled out a set of
terminologies that really weren't
patient specific so here we have heart
chamber last surah CL not quite sure
closed CL I don't even know someone
medications were kind of similar to but
interestingly heart attack was it so
they were basically using they pulled a
medical terminology pull the list from
somewhere I know it's a it's an icd-9
list or an icd-10 list that was then
just cut and pasted into and unfortunate
was cut and pasted into the widget
nobody looked because they looked at
this list of widgets we want this one
that documents health conditions yes
they didn't go deeper and then they
didn't go deeper again the next round
which was he you know it might be a list
it might not be comprehensible we can
make it comprehensible but now it's not
coded to anything that can make it
interoperable so it semantically has no
meaning right and that's where we we
kept bouncing against there was a weird
presentation stuff I was really
surprised by this in and there was an
overview page so your medical summary
gives you your conditions in your
medications so I don't know if the very
back in that pic on I don't think on
anybody can you see how many conditions
there are three how many medications
there are how do they choose that number
it fit on the screen and how do they
choose the order
the reverse order that was entered so
the last medication put on is the top
one so what did i do I dude if we put in
my important medications first and
tylenol and ibuprofen I put on last
right and they everything else fell off
the screen so when you printed this out
to give to your provider you're not
taking anything for your heart except
for a spur again not noticed until we
start touching the system yes they had
they had several committees that had
several committees involved but there
was a lot of control of those committees
and it was which widgets do you want and
they'd say I want to implement nobody
would get down to level until we got
down to the club I'll skip over this one
just finish at a time but there were
certainly widgets that work differently
they were designed by different groups
and so where you put data and one was
not where you put it in the other and
there certainly were some strength I
don't I mean I've shown you the
challenges first intentionally most of
the users in our testing were able to
get into the system pretty comfortably
once they got a login account that
wasn't a big deal and they were able to
move around most places with really
minimal training we intentionally didn't
train a lot of them just to see there
were these health gauges which were
quite quite useful quite liked you know
a blood pressure your latest measurement
whether or not it's it's in range out of
range and you can specify your own
ranges which was good unfortunately this
is where the widget issue came out
though this this LDL cholesterol will
come from the cholesterol widget not
from the lab so if you put it in the
wrong place you wouldn't get a feed
the world quick question of the ages so
we've had a lot of discussion internally
about presenting risk and so I'm just
curious because you have it basically it
was it just normal in high no I think
they have a do they have a near-normal I
think they have a middle they've got an
amber as well any evaluation of
especially when it was more intermediate
of their assessment of it no so how
these ones work is is the the person
with their care team is able to make the
the metric goal so it's not a
measurement of risk it's a measurement
of I'd like to see my blood pressure to
130 on 80 and if it's 145 on 90 it's
high it doesn't say that you've got a
three percent increased risk of stroke
yeah so it's not that smart it's just
kind of a cut off and I think they had
three levels so you could set those
people like the the wellness plans when
they were you know looking at the
specific one that was available alright
so that was all the usability stuff now
we go out to deployment this is our case
study of the of the cardiac rehab clinic
so now we've given the feedback we tried
to fit it in digit 8 it in so that it
gets ready for deployment we did
actually two rounds of usability
inspection one round of usability
testing to try to feed stuff back and
our grant is with the ministry so give
you context there is then a health
authority that actually administers care
and then manages all the hospital
information systems ultimately manages
this personal health record and then
there's the vendor consortium that's
doing the configuration so we are sort
of three arms away so we have we're told
our feedback came back and most issues
with those good news Oh result yes
now interestingly resolve is a result
has a category beside it that you don't
necessarily get to see you just see that
they're all resolved resolved can be
works as designed ie we didn't fix it so
had lots of issues that were close they
were still there the next round that
we're still that of the next round and
there something can't be changed because
of the procurement of the product the
product is this sort of this this design
is the way it is we did a 12-week study
with 12 patients and providers so a
group a cohort of people who had had a
heart attack recently who are then ready
for cardiac rehab in this one city
connected in they got access to the
personal health record and they used it
with their providers there's actually a
provider connection to this as well it
doesn't connect in with the information
system that they would use clinically
but there is a as a window for them to
come in and log in and and communicate a
little bit we did interviews repeat
interviews at zero six and 12 weeks we
had discussion groups where we went out
there and we saw them about halfway
through had a provider discussion group
as well just to learn about how was this
group using this personal health portal
we found a lot of things so availability
so I'm going to come back to our sort of
our initial model the availability was
challenging for some of the providers
just to get logins they were actually
reasonably only had three of the
providers as the other months ago I just
got my login yesterday it's been six
weeks to get it you know the first email
that I use I did it wrong and I couldn't
reuse that email so and I just couldn't
ever get it working in terms of it being
up and live it was up in life the whole
time about wasn't an issue patients in
this study were amazingly dedicated to
the study I had no idea that it's one of
them bought a laptop you've given up all
of his computers and went to a tablet
and that's all he was going to do and
then this study came along says well I
doesn't get a laptop to do that study
bomb
you know a little a lot to do this and
they were logging in regularly trying to
document stuff and most of them at the
ends about I don't know if you need to
do this but I was really glad to be part
of this study the concept of a personal
health record I completely support and I
just hope it gets better clinical
integration was it was an interesting
one I mentioned that some providers just
going to get logged in others were
having a bit of trouble getting it to
their workflow they didn't know should
they log in regularly shouldn't they if
they don't log in on a libel some
attention there's lots of stuff like
that that wasn't clear I didn't mention
but you didn't actually have the
provincial drug information system
linked into the PHR at this point so in
Alberta they have a thing called pin
which is a dispensing record from all
those community pharmacies so we have
this NBC as well or something similar
basically in order to bill out any any
dispensing it gets put into a repository
and then can be viewed by other
clinicians saying emerge or what have
you I use it all the time when I'm
seeing patients the shelter they put a
widget in for this and it's fascinating
to see how that interaction between what
I think I'm taking it and what it's been
dispensed to me it was it was a
challenge that came up patients had a
difficult time understanding what the
dispensing record was and did it mean
that I'm still taking the medication
because I got five of them and it's the
third medication on my list because the
other two I got 90 of it was yeah so it
was really really interesting to see
what and he couldn't do anything with
that data it was just a view before I go
further we kind of wrapped up with that
that group of 12 they finished off their
their study that clinic stopped using it
for the time being they wanted to get
the next version before they were going
to engage their next cohort and they're
still waiting at this point we went off
we finished off that that piece gave the
feedback to
Alberta Health and then they suddenly
had an opportunity to engage cancer
surgery Alberta and there were several
hundred patients that were being
recruited for a study using quality of
life tools and so we did a sort of a
parallel evaluation to that with the
expectation we would use the personal
health record and this quality of life
tool in parallel that the training was
such that the owners of the quality of
life tool didn't want to promote the PHR
and so the PHR wasn't used so we have
this great evaluation for a quality of
life tool 200 cancer surgery Alberta
patients who underwent ongoing follow-up
but it didn't involve the PHR because
turf wars and such they literally use
the login analysis and then pause there
and see if there's questions about first
two targeted yeah so do you really think
it's going to the last thing you said
you really think it's a turf war or do
you think they didn't trust the PHR HR
correct me if I'm wrong is that was the
wrong word but there was there was
certainly an ownership of patients is
what it was so I want I don't want to
distract my patients who were going
through cancer care to do this other
personal health record that I don't know
much about that was such a missed
opportunity for survivorship I think it
was a missed opportunity for a whole
bunch of reasons but what we didn't
doing in our first round of evaluation
was educating people about the PHR and
then some of them went often and used it
so we did get something but it was a
huge missed opportunity
there's a couple in this project as
you're getting the sense of any other
questions about that that initial
targeted deployment so that wrapped up
in 2013 it was and we did the 2013 to 14
we did the cancer surgery and now we're
moving into the next PHR release so
based on what we found in in that first
one with the cardiac group we propose
back to the Alberta Health that we could
look at medication reconciliation we had
this big gap right they were touting the
fact that there's this dispensing record
and yet the patients didn't know what to
make how to make sense of it and I think
this was another missed opportunity so
adherence to medications medication
reconciliation two very important things
that a PHR can help with in my mind if
we're talking about occasions and they
had the provincial dispensing records
already connecting in to a certain
degree but they didn't think about how
to really interface those two so we we
did this small study using a method that
we're adapting called the lead user
method where we look for experts and we
asked them how would they design a
system to do something like medication
reconciliation so we recruited patients
who are who had multiple medications who
had had some experience with clinical
information systems people who had built
personal health records pharmacists and
and a physician and ask them tell me
what's your ideal system and why tell me
how it should work and we would
visualize it show it back to them so we
actually gave them their idealized
system and as a mock-up HTML or I think
this time we used a product called
omnigraffle just to sketch out of
wireframes and but they could click on
them into the move through it and we had
multiple versions of their individually
idealized med rec process and then we
synthesized those down into some
recommendations in a design for the PHR
that is how we started to modify our
approach to to changing evaluation
as opposed to just talking about what we
think you should evaluate what the
potential value is now we're actually
trying to feed in you know design ideas
and requirements into the process based
on our evaluation they weren't they they
were expecting that report they weren't
expecting the report that makes sense
they didn't know how to respond to a new
set of requirements that came out of
this this pre-release evaluation and
then right now where we're sitting in
this next cycle is the vendor has taken
away a whole bunch of the requirements
they're putting the version 2 out we'll
be getting access to it about two months
time to be able to look at the next
version of the PHR yeah you guys can
question of it good the you had a real
opportunity there for you described all
of these bugs that were fixed works as
described where it was clear that users
were like this is an optimal and this
isn't working and I'm wondering if those
were reconciled in the idealized designs
or maybe it's because you only focus on
medication reconciliation yes because
it's a good question medric didn't exist
at all as a product in there so it
wasn't like we said well here's health
conditions and this is what we think the
new one should be we did lots of
discussion about that in our usability
recommendation so we said you know
here's the challenge like that deep
navigation surface the navigation app
have a summary screen don't have a
summary screen it only shows the last
three medications this is what it should
look like it so there was lots of
recommendation like that medric was
different in that it didn't exist at all
so it was completely new so yeah so
where we're sitting now usability
hopefully for the new version and
they've now had a year and a half to
embed some of the changes they went very
quiet for a while they've gone back to
the anonymous website with more content
so they're building that up but they
haven't rereleased the PHR we're going
to see it soon hopefully there'll be
some more significant changes than what
we saw the first round and they're
planning a general public launch for the
beginning of 2016 so it will be websites
on everybody come
so from an evaluation perspective in
terms of a method to recruit and
randomize it and that's not going to be
an option again we need to think of new
ways and I'd be really interested to see
what people would think of in terms of
deployment evaluation when something
gets turned on and anybody could could
technically go in with Alberta Health
number and get an account how do we try
to structure an evaluation that it
increases the rigor as opposed to just a
case then so how about I pause there and
see if anyone's got an answer to my
tough question
one of the things that we thought about
was a be testing so embedding two
versions of the same widget and ten
percent people get wanted that's fallen
on well there's a couple of challenges
that the leadership help with trying to
embed stuff by that experimental things
into it into a real system which of
course boggles me but because it's all
experimental but yeah I think the audit
trails is one place to go for sure it's
called Healthlink yes so if you can call
them back that means you're tracking
them so they must tell you who they are
and give you their help in health but
yes right so I'm just curious what I
mean because one thing that I think of
which is a slightly different question
than you're interested in but it's kind
of what the pattern is if there's a
drop-off or if you have certain because
you have the ability to ask with help
link if they've been using the portal or
not and can start to see if you see
patterns especially depending on the
type of call and I have no idea how
structured that data is really because
it seems like that would be an amazing
opportunity to look at patterns are
there certain calls are now getting
diverted diverted to the portal where
you because you would know that the user
is using the portal versus using health
link or are you seeing a pattern where
they use the portal leave and now we're
just using our back to using health link
and those those trends can tell you a
lot in terms of behavior and what we saw
is an increase in referrals back to the
portal versus emerge because the ongoing
joke is that the nurse lines always just
send you to emerge what no matter what
protocol you start with you end up go to
emerge and that's not not the case
obviously but there was a lot more
heading
back to the portal which was which was
interesting and the patients would
acknowledge that's what they didn't did
you actually checked that right uh
because you know that they love you know
who I guess I'm getting it you know who
they are also in that study we we knew
who they were in the call but we
couldn't track her they were logging or
going to the website because it wasn't a
login it was just an anonymous now once
we have the portal or when we do have
the portal we would we would potentially
be able to link those two and i think
that's it that's actually a very good
how do we structure to link those two
you know the other thought besides the a
B would be to do kind of the classic
knew where the user has the ability to
change the interface and you can track
that so that you can start to see
especially in this is commonly done in
rollouts right so before you roll out
you actually offer the new view and then
they can go back to the old and you can
monitor private option but it seems like
there's a place for this here especially
when you think about novel ways to
visualize or present data back to them
absolutely i think i'll have to i'm
going to take that one away to see if
the team over there will be able to or
be willing to do but that's a good
yeah so so we looked at it from it most
of its political so it you know if we
say well let's let's randomized to
cities thinking well we can't make
Edmonton mad because if edmonton's mad
you know because there's two big cities
right so is Edmonton and Calgary you see
well okay let's give it to any camp in
Calgary mad because some say well let's
give it to the cardiologist in Calgary
and the respirology in Edmonton and then
we'll reverse to the next time that was
as close as we got that's where the
delayed cohort idea came from so we can
effectively take two cohorts in each
city each group gets it and then each
group gets at three to six months later
they weren't too happy with the idea
that we would randomized and nobody
would get it but effectively you could
you could sort of yeah you could do it
you could do a stepped wedge kind of
design now they're moving to this that
was the targeted rollouts where they
were trying to link it into a clinic in
a program now they're moving to this
general public launch because they kind
of want it out the door and I think it's
going to be very hard if they do a large
advertisement for it that you can then
say only people who log in on X number
of minutes get access to it I don't
think they'd be open to that
yeah I think I mean ultimately there is
going to be it's it's a voluntary
program and they're not going to get a
huge percentage of people i mean i think
i think kaiser probably has the one of
the higher numbers that I've seen in
terms of you know suppose it adoption of
a personal health record and that's
that's nowhere near half its I'd see
numbers close to a quarter but I suspect
these folks will be less than ten
percent probably significantly less
until they get links into can I ask for
a refill can I book an appointment once
you have those and there's a reason for
me to log in to do with the baby yep
guys can we get a better version and
then those cords are similar enough yeah
yeah I think I think that might be
possible like again if they're going
directly to consumer though you might
you might say all these dogs agreed not
to promote it within the clinic but you
know they got they got a mail out in the
mail and so my patients have started to
use it anyway I think it's going to be
the opposite i think it's going to be a
recruitment challenge you know if the
past is is indicative of what's coming
that's going to be the bigger issue
people will log in and that those curves
that i showed you at the beginning you
know of everything going up there's
going to be a blip up and then the
tapering off this is what i would i
wouldn't be surprised to see just in
terms of its its flashy it's interesting
but where's the value
couple modules in there the value that
adds occasion you get the tipping point
that you get enough model where you get
the right now
and there are more now or there will be
more soon and I'm quite seen what's
their next but that's the intention
thank you now it is 1230 exactly so
should we pause there yeah yeah I've got
I've got time afterwards absolutely
thank you it was thank